what would you make of the home
secretary's comments about stop and
search are they useful in any way
well at the moment we'd there has never
been any evidence to suggest that
increasing stop and search is going to
have a fundamental difference
um in the community that they're
targeting I think what will happen is
that you're going to have
a lot of members of the community being
targeted unnecessarily because of the
way the police operate already in the
terms of racial bias towards certain
communities especially in the black
community
so I think that um unless there is
proper Intel
um to suggest that they're going to
increase stop and search in a certain
area or in a certain Community they need
to think how are they going to do this
without further alienating the black
community because we've seen this before
back in the 80s this is more my time the
seven is an 80s there was a massive
increase in the South law and they came
in and swamped South London and that
alienated a large percentage of the
black community which then caused the
outbreaks of the uprisings in 1981. I
think I'm not suggesting that's going to
happen in this case but what I will
suggest is that this will definitely
further alienate the black community
um because of the way the police already
operate within that Community what could
be done
improve the relations between the police
and and local communities well I think
the first thing that has to happen if
you want to improve relationships is
that you have to admit that
institutional racism actually exists in
their institutions and I'm not
suggesting by any means that
institutional racism is just firmly
placed at the police it's in all sector
of the society it's in corporate
businesses it's in the financial sector
it's in the education the local
Authority the NHS I can go on so it
isn't just the police that is
institutional racism it's a society it's
a societal problem but I think the
police not admitting that or should I
say Mark Rowley not admitting that is
actually the biggest problem because you
can't fix something if you're not
willing to admit that we have a problem
in the first place
But but so admitting that that there is
racism is one thing but but changing
recruitment would that make a difference
oh 100 I think the recruitment process
has to be addressed
um and I would go as fast as say they
need to have a psychological assessment
done at the interview stage of every
police officer that wants to become a
police officer especially existing
police officers because I think the
biggest problem we have in the UK are
existing police officers and I think if
we can have a psychological assessment
done on the way some of these police
officers think their understanding of
certain communities or lack of
understanding will then weed out
officers who have bad intentions or who
do not understand cultural differences
within the certain communities in
certain parts of the UK or especially in
London
how do you think
we could life crime
that's a very good question I think this
is a societal problem I think it's not
just a case of more stop and search but
it's a case of every person taking
active interest in their children taking
active in stressing what's going on in
society I think if we start looking at
police we're going to find the police
alienate in the black community so I
think Society has to take a better stand
parent in parents schools every one of
us has a duty to make sure our children
are not walking streets with weapons but
also there is a fair in certain
communities around the gangs around
certain things so I think we have to get
rid of the fear we have to raise good
expectations we've got to make young
people feel a part of society at the
moment many young people don't feel a
part of society and so it's easy for
them to be groomed into this lifestyle
of carrying weapons and when you listen
to a lot of young people they believe
that carrying weapons is part of their
life now and so we've got to get rid of
that stigma as well
the Home Secretary talking tough to
police officers do you think that in any
way filters down to kids on the street
I think their own secretary has issues
of our own that has to be addressed
because for Home Secretary
um especially an army secretary from the
Asian Community
um not believing that this country um
that this Society has institutional
problems
um is is really a problem for us in the
community because if you can't admit
that institutional racism exists and you
have suffered
um maybe not in the same way as of of
black kids or
then I think that's a problem in itself
but the rest of it about this kind of
Hardline approach
um we've seen it all before like I said
and it's never made a big difference in
our community this Hardline approach I
think what needs to happen is looking at
recruitment processes looking at the
kind of police officers who want to join
the force kind of looking at
um looking at a psychological assessment
of every single police officer existing
once and new records and the most
important thing is to get the community
more involved in the training process I
think that lacks in the police force I
think we need more community members
especially from the black community
to be a part of that training process
because it can't just be a
lastminute.com or a couple of days
training we need the um the community to
be a part of the
um their training processes from the
beginning right through their career